cyber attacks on companies and people
are at an all-time high as the country
continues to struggle to fill cyber
security jobs that's where UNLV comes in
with its gen cyber camp for high
schoolers Candace Charles has more about
the program
my big wish with this industry is uh you
know just bringing about innovation in
the world Leonardo Guerrero's dreams are
out of this world the Gin cyber Camp is
helping him take his aspirations and
talents to new heights it's just uh you
know something that you kind of have to
pick up to help out others cyber attacks
continue to make headlines while the
National Security Agency works hard to
fill jobs right now there are three
quarter million open positions in cyber
security we have a huge challenge in
this country UNLV computer science
professors Johan Kim and Julian Joe run
this gen cyber Camp they tell me the NSA
and the National Science Foundation gave
the College of Engineering grants to
help fill those gaps since its start
five years ago they've seen High School
participants come through the program to
univ some are now Tas for the camp we
are excited to see them growing and then
showing those those interests
SD High School participants learn from
cyber Security Experts about topics such
as cyber crimes and protection
encryption techniques and more through
Hands-On activities Protectors of the
World Wide Web it's something Guerrero
tells me is what he and his gen cyber
campmates are working so hard for having
a world where you can be very protected
and uh you know you can just you know be
safe because it's a it's a crazy world
out there especially in you know the
digitized world at UNLV I'm Candace
Charles 8 news now UNLV says they plan
on creating a ba program just for cyber
security you can still sign your child
up for the fall session and the 2024
sessions we'll have those details on our
website 8newsnow.com